if you have to sell really hard it's
because your branding is wrong it means
you haven't provided enough value in
advance despite being able to teach
somebody who has no brand how to make
enough money to pay their rent and
whatnot there's a better way and the
better way to do it is be a little bit
more patient rather than just going for
the jugular on the first call that
you've ever met somebody actually
breadcrumb provide a little bit of value
provide a little bit more provide a
little bit more and then wait until they
ask and then it becomes a much easier
conversation and your pricing can be 10
times higher now you've created demand
rather than artificially stimulating
through Brute Force